tonight joe biden is going to speak or
at least he's supposed to speak and then
we'll all watch
with bated breath to see whether he
actually makes it through his speech
he's going to propose another 2 trillion
package so just to get this straight
since his election he's proposed a 4
trillion
budget 2 trillion dollars and blow out
coveted spending that we didn't need
two trillion dollars in infrastructure
spending that is nothing with
infrastructure and now two trillion
dollars
to expand education and safety net
programs so by my account this is about
10 trillion dollars that he's proposed
in spending
in his first three months on the job
that's crazy downs okay that's nuts
we already have a record in national
debt i know some people on the right
didn't care about the national debt when
trump was president i did
i talked about it i talked about how we
were spending too much money and how it
was deeply irresponsible
try taking that and then multiplying it
by a factor of like two and a half
and you get to exactly where joe biden
is today donald trump is blowing out the
budget at the tune of about four
trillion dollars a year joe biden is
suggesting blowing out the budget at the
tune of 10
trillion dollars okay for people on the
left say well
republicans have no credibility here
republicans overspend but there is a
difference
between overspending to the tune of 4
trillion and overspending to the tune of
you know 10 trillion
the the super heating of the american
dollar i mean the dollar is going to
explode
okay the dollar is going to decrease in
value in extraordinary ways over the
coming years
meanwhile joe biden is making it
impossible for if you have any money to
invest it anywhere
they're going to be real impacts to the
stuff that he's talking about but joe
biden is going for broke and the reason
he's going for broke is basically he's
one from president he wants to make his
mark before he leaves
that's all this is that's the only
reason i can explain what he's doing
because again he gained office on the
promise
that he was going to be a moderate who
worked with the other side and you took
a slow
incremental approach to government and
restored normalcy and here he is
proposing two trillion dollars of
spending essentially every three weeks
of his presidency
which is nuts according to the
washington post the white house on
wednesday unveiled a 1.8 trillion
spending and tax plan aimed at
dramatically expanding access to
education and safety net programs for
families
the package cannot be implemented
without congressional approval many
republicans have offered a cool
reception to the scope of tax increases
and the spending that biden has tried to
advance but the white house's new
american family's plan
provides congress with details of the
president's domestic agenda setting down
markers for negotiations later this year
now
spare me the notion that democrats are
deeply concerned about helping american
families this is the same group of
people
who have routinely downplayed the
importance of the
nuclear family in american life and have
attempted to destroy all
of the of the institutions that help out
families in the social sphere
particularly with regard to religious
communities and churches
and this idea that they're out there to
defend american families know what
they're really out there to do is make
the government father again
right just as it was in the 1960s to the
great detriment of so many
actual families around the united states
biden's plan according to the washington
post proposes a suite of domestic
policies that would collectively
represent a marked change in how
americans interact with the federal
government the white house says its
proposal would provide every american
with two years of tuition free community
college question what does that have to
do with families
why is it important that you have two
years of tuition free community college
one of the good things about not funding
free community college is that you are
not
paying people to go to a crappy junior
arts college
and get a degree in nothing it turns out
that if you want to get a degree in
science in a stem field there are plenty
of banks willing to offer you a student
loan
you know why because you'll probably
repay it the thing about education loans
is there's no collateral
okay so when banks don't want to give
you a loan for your education
maybe the reason is because you are
getting a degree in a useless subject
okay but now we're all supposed to fund
your this journey of self-discovery in
college
you ever notice having language
surrounding what college was supposed to
be changed
right college used to be okay we're
going to train you for a job you'll
learn something about citizenship
you'll learn sort of the things that
everybody must know now it's like you go
to college to find yourself and have the
college experience i don't want to pay
for your summer camp i'm not interested
i went to college not all that long ago
and i can tell you there are people
there who are serious about learning
they're what we used to call ucla south
campus majors you know the stem fields
and then there are the people who are
there to party
and get decent grades and then move on
to law school or just get a degree have
the credential and then move on into the
job force
and party and mostly party and also
party
this is why there's such focus on you
have to be have the college experience
the college life we all know what that's
code for
okay so now joe biden wants you to pay
for it
pre-kindergarten for all three and
four-year-olds which makes perfect sense
except for the fact that head start has
been one of the largest failures in
american governmental history
if you look at the record of head start
it has provided virtually no benefit
to the kids who have been a part of head
start also as
people like elizabeth warren used to
suggest she wrote a book called the two
income trap
back when she was actually an
interesting politician in the early
2000s elizabeth warren suggested that
perhaps
funding things like universal child care
or early education
actually drove families to put both
members of the
of the parental crew in the workforce
artificially driving up housing prices
artificially creating shortages in the
labor force
and creating unemployment and by the way
giving kids a worse quality of life in
many cases because it turns out the kids
generally do better with mom
or dad at home than they do in a random
daycare facility
again this is not a referendum on
whether women should work i don't care
when i was
when i was at home when when i was a kid
my dad was at home with us and my mom
worked
right now my wife is a doctor right i'm
all in favor of women who want to work
working
but the notion that you have to
incentivize a family
for both parents to work that has to be
the incentive for both families to work
and we're going to
make an actual in we're going to do
we're going to essentially make it
harder
for women to stay home and fathers to
work or the opposite
is not actually good public policy paid
family and medical leave
for american workers which again
this this is basically designed to
alleviate the consequences of personal
choice
right the idea is that no one should
should lose benefit
in their their career trajectory for
taking time out of the american
workforce
question why why
i it's a choice we all have choices
those choices come with consequences the
great lie of modern society is that you
can have everything you want
and that somebody else will pay for it
that ain't the way real life works
okay but that is joe biden's proposal
the plan also calls for devoting
hundreds of billions of dollars to
fighting child poverty and ensuring
affordable child care
nationwide again to try and ram people
into the workforce
also the idea of devoting hundreds of
billions to fighting child poverty what
they mean by that is signing checks to
parents
that has never been an effective way of
fighting child poverty
the left believes the way you fight
poverty in the long run is just you sign
people checks that is not effective we
have spent 22 trillion dollars in the
war on poverty
precisely the same percentage of
americans are living under the poverty
line now
as we're living under the poverty line
when we started the war on poverty the
way that you actually get out of poverty
is you incentivize
good choices you incentivize things like
waiting to have babies until you are
financially stable
and getting married and getting a job
right these are the ways you actually
get kids out of poverty
not by signing checks if signing checks
just got kids out of poverty
fewer kids would be in poverty today
that's for damn sure since we've been
signing checks at record rates for
decades in the united states
to pay for all of this white house
officials are proposing 1.5 trillion
in tax hikes oh yeah that won't have any
downside
also they're going to spend 80 billion
on the irs costs 80
billion at the worst agency in american
life and they're gonna double the
capital gains tax for people earning
more than a million bucks a year which
makes perfect sense
we're gonna destroy the value of the
dollar and then give people no place to
put their money
brilliant well bitcoin to the moon gang
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content